Good morning, Hank, it’s Tuesday.
So Yesterday, Sarah and I flew to New York
City.
The descent was just a bit bumpy, but we landed
safely, drove into the city, and met up with
our best friends, Chris and Marina.
Chris: Good morning, America.
I was wearing my fancy shoes because we were
in town for the premiere of the movie Miss
Peregrine’s Home for Peculiar Children.
Got a delicious lunch of sushi, where I irrevocably
stained my dress shirt, so we headed over
to a department store, where there were too
many ties to choose from.
If it looks like I hate trying on clothes,
that’s because I do.
But I eventually found a suitable shirt, and
then put the stained shirt back on so as not
to stain the new one, and went for a walk.
I love walking in New York, even in uncomfortable
shoes, because you’re both alone and not
in a way I find deeply satisfying, even peaceful.
I also love catching snippets of strangers’
conversations.
“Don’t you have to like someone to love
them?” one young person said to another
as they walked past me.
We walked through an outdoor bookstore, where
I sneakily signed some copies of Looking for Alaska
And then on my way to the hotel, I happened
across a Crash Course fan.
John: What’s your name again?
Kerry: Kerry
John: And then I ran into Kerry!
Kerry: Big fan.
John’s awesome
We checked into our aggressively gold hotel
room, I ironed my new shirts, suited up, and
then got in the elevator.
I don’t like this tie.
I then met up with Ransom Riggs, the author
of Miss Peregrine.
John: It’s all voiceover—
Ransom: Oh
John: so it doesn’t really matter what you
say
I’ve known Ransom for half my life.
Like, when we were in college together, we
took a road trip to the Grand Canyon with
our friend Kathy.
Are you taking pictures of me, dude?
We read James Joyce together and wrote comedy
sketches together, and I was always in awe
of Ransom’s imagination.
I think ultimately my favorite feeling isn’t
joy or excitement, but wonder.
The wonder I feel when walking through an
autumn forest with my kid who’s never before
seen the leaves turn color, or the wonder
I feel when in the company of a great book
or movie.
Hanging out Ransom always brings me that kind
of wonder because he has such a particular
and interesting way of looking at the world,
and that’s also how I feel about his books.
They wonderful, in the original sense of the
word.
After hanging out for a while, I went back
to my room
Changed my tie
And then met up with Sarah
John: I don’t look as nice as you do, but
I look all right.
Sarah: No, you look awesome! I love it.
And then my publisher, Julie Strauss-Gable,
dropped by, and we all headed to the movie
theatre for the screening.
Before the movie, Ransom and his wife, the
brilliant novelist Tahereh Mafi, posed on
the red carpet, and I snuck back to be among
the photographers.
And then I took my seat, where I caught a
magikarp.
Now we shall cut from the magikarp to me turning
on the camera after the move ended.
You can’t see me but I just saw the movie
and it’s so good!
Miss Peregine made me feel the way Edward
Scissorhands did decades ago.
It was exciting and peculiar, and explored
with great wisdom the tension between the
past you did have, the one you wanted to have,
and the present you find yourself in.
And that’s what I kept thinking about as
I watched Ransom and Tahereh on the red carpet
after the movie.
Like, if you told me twenty years ago that
this day would happen, I would have thought,
“That’s gonna be so cool, going to a movie
premiere, all dressed up, people taking our
pictures while we hang out with movie stars."
And it is cool.
Ransom and I have both been astonishingly
lucky in our professional lives.
But the really wonderful part of yesterday
for me wasn’t the movie stars or the red carpet.
It was seeing a great movie with my wife and
dear friends, one of whom has known me since
I was a kid on the edge of the Grand Canyon,
before I’d even learned to fear heights.
In the end, I think people make experiences
wonderful, not the other way around.
Hank, I’ll see you on Friday,